it's round 2 of the government's loan
program to help small businesses got off
to a pretty rocky start banks had
problem getting loan applications into
the Small Business Administration's
overwhelmed computer system yesterday
another 310 billion dollars is available
after the initial two hundred forty nine
billion dollars ran out in just 13 days
at O'Keefe has that story this program
was developed to help small companies
and I think that's where they need to
start and look at first samantha Knecht
rowe runs a pennsylvania furniture
company that makes seats for mass
transit trains it's been pretty much
crickets
it wasn't until last week the 22nd that
I was able to finally get my application
submitted was already completely going
for connect row and other small business
owners news that organizations like the
LA Lakers were approved for a loan it's
tough to take the Lakers are valued at
more than four billion dollars and have
said they're returning the 4.6 million
they received from the program I'm not
spiteful for anybody who did receive
funds Scott wood owns the courtyard
brewery in New Orleans and was hoping
for a forty thousand dollar loan to stay
afloat it kind of makes for an unfair
situation like we're the ones who really
need the help and a lot of us aren't
getting it even with the additional
funding now available Rob Nichols head
of the American Bankers Association said
banks struggled on Monday to submit
applications launched this week was a
little frustrating
you had banks that are desperate to help
their millions of small business
customers and clients all across the
country and the access to the system
today was a little choppy Nichols warned
that was about 30 million small
businesses nationwide the second round
of aid is also likely to run out quickly
in the first round you had about two
million small businesses that blew
through that 350 billion more than two
billion dollars has been returned or
declined so far and will be made
available to others the Bankers
Association says that banks need more
guidance and how exactly to quickly get
that funding to their customers and
Samantha can esto who you heard from
there at the beginning of the piece
tells me she
needs to know by the end of this week
whether she's getting that assistance or
she's gonna have to start cutting back
Anthony the dilemma for small business
as a goldman sachs survey found 90% of
the small businesses in their program
had applied for the loan said 70% still
waiting not a good number
thanks